psychism is the view that Consciousness
goes right down to the fundamental
building blocks of reality I mean it's a
question for physics right what the
fundamental building blocks of reality
are maybe the particles maybe the
universe wide Fields but whatever they
are the idea is that they have
incredibly simple rudimentary forms of
experience so nothing like the kind of
experience a human being has after
millions of years of evolution and as we
move to simpler and simpler forms of
life we find simpler and simpler forms
of subjective experience for the pans
psychist that keeps going right down to
the fundamental building blocks of
reality that have incredibly simple
forms of experience